president biden wants to greatly expand
his domestic plans and they come with a
big price tag
he's seeking a 1.5 trillion dollar
package for his administration's 2022
budget while giving the military
only a small increase something
republicans have already
challenged christina ruffini is at the
white house with more christina good
morning
good morning dana you know presidential
budgets are rarely adopted by congress
think of them more as guidelines
a road map of where they would like the
spending to go and what was unveiled
this week was actually not a full budget
but a preview
of the bigger blockbuster budget to come
later this year
but the trailer is already causing some
controversy
i sent to congress my my funding
priorities for the appropriations
process president biden's priority list
is growing
and it isn't cheap in addition to the
nearly two trillion dollar stimulus bill
passed in march
and a two trillion dollar infrastructure
plan the white house yesterday unveiled
pieces of its 1.5 trillion
dollar spending plan a preview of his
fiscal 2022 budget
the proposal includes an increase of 118
billion dollars
for non-military discretionary spending
money to fight things like climate
change
global health crisis including pandemics
education
and foreign aid to combat corruption and
reduce poverty
in the central american countries
fueling the migration crisis at the
southern border
i look forward to working with congress
to advance these and other priorities
i think we're going to be able to get
i'm hoping we'll have some bipartisan
support across the board
as for military spending it suggests a
modest bump
of 1.7 far less than the previous
increases under the trump administration
we believe it provides a robust funding
level for the military forces
needed to deter war and ensure nation
security in a joint statement with other
senate republicans
minority leader mitch mcconnell said
without more money for the military
america will lose its edge over
strategic competitor
china talk is cheap it reads but
defending our country
is not also pricey fixing the country's
crumbling
infrastructure i have yet to talk to
anybody who
including in conversations with
republicans who is against the idea of a
big
investment in infrastructure republicans
say that bill is too expensive and
object to the president's proposal to
raise corporate tax rates to defray the
cost
most of the dialogue we're having is
around how we're going to pay for it
and as if republicans in the white house
didn't have enough to argue about
this week the president launched a
commission to study potential supreme
court reforms
that includes term limits and what's
referred to as court packing
or adding an additional justice now
there is no set number of jurors in the
constitution
but it stayed at nine since after the
civil war jeff
all right christina thank you